hello everyone it's the last segment of
III at GameSpot the most energy I've had
all week
welcome to the GameSpot stage we are
joined by some friends uh Lucy James as
always no we got Mary Kish
former King spider twitches own now got
Brandon Jones from easy allies and Greg
Miller from kind of funny okay I know no
let me tell you the virtues a subscriber
to youtube.com slash trying to fight
against killing every day we are kind of
funny games daily it's fantastic you got
a shirt on already that's right
pride this shirt that you can get hey
you're kind of funny y'all calm slash
store right now is it on discount I
don't know I doubt it I think he's done
so I'm gonna move on we are here to rank
the some of the best III 2019 trailers
cuz I bought these on Amazon and I'm
going to expense it and I need a reason
I have to justify the expense so we have
some marker boards we told Mary nuts or
anything too vulgar well let's see what
happens uh what are some like we have a
list of trailers cued up so if you go
off-topic it'll probably spend away
jean-luc
he'll figure it out I'm gonna start mine
was death loop yes yeah yeah then we
just send the panel death loop I was
hoping for something from arcane this
was an awesome announcement not at all
what I expected which is super cool
arcade Leona obviously without dinga
back Abba who incidentally the creative
director does like parkour like legit
before the Bethesda conference started
Harvey Smith was tweeting out videos of
him doing like side flips and [ __ ] while
they were doing sound tests anyway death
loop looks super cool the people who
made dishonored pray if you want go back
farther arc spate Alice Messiah dark
messiah of might of magic video I'm I
know arcane we've done a we talked about
it they don't they weren't super clear
on exactly how the game is going to work
but they did some cool things with pray
moon crash so I imagine that would kind
of transfer over into depth with Beth
Luba characters resurrecting whatnot
groundhog day style thing what do you
think when you think of the gameplay
what do you think of they've said first
person the first person janitors in the
press release my pitch is right that
these two assassins one played by Dave
fennoy from Dave fennoy comp going after
each other trying to kill each other my
assumption is
we switch off as we go and like you're
on these missions to kill the other
person you kill the other person then
you wake up is the person you just
killed and do it all over that's not it
that sounds super cool because I when I
first saw the two characters I was
thinking dishonor - you pick Emily or
Corvo yeah but that sounds way cooler
but I do think it's time for like arcane
can clearly make immersive Sims probably
no one else around today it's making
them as well they've proven that I'd
like to see them do something cool like
you just mentioned uh either way this
trailer was also just really good just
dope yeah yeah it's so good and just
lots of great stylistic stuff though I
didn't see a lot of trailers do you love
trailers just straight game playing
there's really fun transitions and it's
weird cuz it's like super sci-fi
desolate but almost kind of has like a
spy 50s vibe not that oh right it's you
down hope adventure almost like a 70s
those ever I hope cabaret okay a lot of
things right now they're taking place in
the future so it's really cool to have
something stylized 70s maybe yeah ish
style yes when they started off it
looked like you know the cutscenes and
just wanted to the kind of cartoony
looking of just you know two images
slowly fading over each other it's sort
of looking on that and then it went into
that which is now long no longer
on-screen but you know what I'm getting
it right which is really cool and I just
think it was submitted what I thought it
would be oh yeah because arcane's done
steampunk ish well blubber money
whatever arcane was sorry dishonored was
prey sci-fi arcs fate Alice more like a
and Dark Messiah were all medieval kind
of fantastical stuff and this is just
weird and I like it you know we could
probably do actually be easier we could
rate them I got it oh yeah yeah I'll
keep track of the scores as we go oh my
god I got my calculators do the math in
my head is gonna retain all those
numbers in maps inevitably Eric scales
the matter with hundred point scale what
are we out of five out of five injury
are coming let's see that work I was
like use the GameSpot scale yeah well no
sorry yet we are on a gauge hot stage
let's do out of ten out of ten no halves
Oh numbers whole numbers yeah I'm on it
okay what do you say when do we urge on
Luke's gonna keep track awesome awesome
okay do you want to yeah i'm gonna write
one down when i say flip them
cheat loose all right flip them yep yep
yeah like 8:05 average eight tonight who
would have thought the two smartest
people on the panel together oh yeah
yeah we could opinions yeah now are the
right ones right you know I mean John
Luke II got that three eights and two 9s
all right what's uh what's next trailer
we're gonna do so I did expense the
whiteboard and I pulled the Pens you
expense the erasers no I did not marry
no I did I'm sure films all right they
can just throw away at the end of my
list just in case but we do have the
breath of the wild sequel trailer ready
to rock which was a huge surprise yeah
for me are we are we rating based on the
game or on the trailer
it is this an unscientific process yeah
trailer specifically specifically that's
a good point that's a very good point I
didn't think about that she host um
yeah basically trailers you're hosting a
game very wide Yuki [ __ ] lazy sorry
it's really little I have yeah I laugh
all right yeah well we'll bring the
trailer up a legend of Legend of Zelda
breath of the wild sequel I think it
confused a lot of people because it's
got all this Twilight Princess II music
and kind of though dark those effects
but then it zooms out and shows what
looks like Hyrule from breath and wild
anywho they then said breath of the wild
sequel coming so then I just blew
everybody's nips off it was great it was
awesome like turn at the end of their
direct which was already pretty solid
because they're not on the cusp of that
console generation right so they're like
what just going out all in on games
oh also let's make announced a sequel to
I think is arguably one of the best
games ever made uh I don't know what you
guys think about this before we rate it
brandy I think it's one of those things
weird to me it's the excitement of the
game it's the excitement for the
potential would it be the actual
structure of the trailers like all right
exactly
get it up what's kind of also like death
loop like one of my major criticism so
that would be I wish I knew a little bit
more I would say and not know more but I
wish there were clues that I could kind
of torture and what's going on yeah I
think this is intentionally obtuse but
then you know for me a truck this one I
mean it gives off the vibe right there
Majora's Mask in it yeah I cry I'm going
to be the world you already
no but with this dark evil in Italian
you know through I don't know man Hyrule
Castle has taken off into space so
that's we're gonna be on the moon
wow really on the moon so I was going up
or was it was it I because it was
rumbling I don't know if they show going
up what if it's sinking yeah yeah
terminals around video another time
which way as we all also it's worth
noting that this is probably much
farther from being done than death oh
yes yeah right
definitely is all right we're N key yeah
looks pretty girl ask your favorite
Zelda my favorite game ever made well
frame was your favorite game if
somebody's not numbers they're gonna be
a little partial that yeah we'll see I'm
biased oh you want to do a objective
scores okay all right everybody ready
yeah flip them boom oh oh yeah where do
you this happening i I think I played
time I'm with Brandon I think it
could've been mine right
I'm Brett it was an awesome trailer was
a swerve going on I like I like the
announcement more than the trailer yeah
yeah we're in I was kind of are we not
supposed to factor in so of people's
excitement
oh yeah which people exploded cuz that's
why I went - guys if that was fresh
again what oh no I know if we're
affecting that and that we're all get
tens I think for people's excitement it
changes our trail okay trailers John
Luke six seven seventy seven eight eight
oh I already erased I don't know eyes
looking for eraser alright next trailer
by the list I would pull it out um
control the new III control trailer
which control it's odd because it's
about a month and a half away yes
playing it bringing up the trailer right
now behind us this game every time this
game was so easy to sell just watch it
for like five minutes yeah uh if you
like weird crap here's a game that's all
weird like David Lynch yeah Thomas and
me Kyle from the team came on stage to
talk about it they were saying their aim
this year for e3 was to show more of the
emotional narrative side right like I
said as soon as you see control and even
the people who played it they're like
yeah I'm sold yeah feels awesome it
looks awesome they were showing us more
characters kind of the flavor of the
story I liked it I think
it's kind of an unfair criticism for me
but because we've already seen so much
the gameplay that just looks awesome
already I think I would I just want to
keep seeing that but it was a little
thing one for more narrative thing but
the thing about this trailer though
short yeah 45 surely 35 yeah well you're
to the point you have to stop showing
things yeah you have to sell people on
the game but you can't like yeah really
push it out I'm saying yeah you think
there's gonna be like serious spoilers
going on in the story there general oh
you the janitor would you be able to
know it's a spoil I wouldn't know what
you're looking at gonna be I went back
in time and spending [ __ ] alright try
them down uh here you go
Lucy control my remedy I don't know I
forget the exact release date end of
July I believe yeah does anybody know
here live audience 25 July 27 Oh June 27
August 27 desirey about everybody third
guest thank you very much thank you
August 27th control by remedy yeah all
right flip them okay I continue like
rolling yeah no I like to
double-crossing swine been a minute yeah
whop my god oh yeah so I liked it but at
the same time we are very close to
release I think even that trailer from
last year told me everything I wanted to
know about it so this was just a nice
old flavor piece and accoutrement yeah
ELISA bouche animoves
um Lucy I'm gonna have you lead for a
little bit while I pull up the list but
we can close seapunk double Seva's I've
been calling it it's I really has been
rolling at that 27 finally oh yeah
deep funk 27 well I have said see Punk
77 and then Andy Cortez like now see
Punk double sev damn that's good
I know I feel like that got a really
nice right over there so awesome hang on
a week counting it's been really on he
is in the trailer he really I think it
was by the way I was answering your
question before you even counting the
adorable bit at the end where he was
like trailer just evidence yeah you see
on the screen I don't know he hasn't
finished it this
what well let's agree that was awesome
yes but let's just judge from the
trailer um Chuck thank you
yeah Mike and I finally got to see the
presentation today this is a momentous
occasion for me by the way now great
right yeah I remember last e3 when they
were showing like the I scene and
everyone was freaking out now earlier
coming back and they're showing so much
more it's so much it's like so exciting
to see people who saw just like Louie
and I very quick I video and now we're
like seeing so much more of this game
alright you're saying where you are
everybody ready all right yeah flip them
whoa oh yeah hey yeah what do we have to
do I don't know I'm just uh sorry David
Fillion didn't show up I just leaned
800-1000 a huge fan of Keanu but we're
talking about the trailer all together
now right yeah but though you know
Jackie gets done in and you want
emotional residence right and yes
reaction last year like building him up
as a character like he was one of the
main focal points of the whole demo I
which I figured out that I've now seen
four times I just have 40-plus minute
demo four times and I was like Tiffin's
gets shot and seemingly died it looks
really good I'm not saying it doesn't
look good
I'm just saying eight where I come from
an eight is garbage show that the saying
is eight is great is that not the case
eight people don't I just sure - fun
times easy to remember is uh admissible
when it is cops head is the best oh you
tell me for gamespot yeah necessary yeah
so that's why I said it was a momentous
occasion second ten out of ten of my
life I've ever given look at the games
about review score where it's essential
to have watched though uh I think this
balances with last year's trailer really
well - last year was like very much
about the city seeing like a slice of
life just across the board and this like
not only focusing on the character more
but we're meeting characters that we met
last year again and what much more
impact here comes the gourds yeah yeah
all right good scores all around
gentleman probably got him by now
let's move on to another game watch him
get its hands cut off another game that
actually has a real release date - e7
remake you and far between and 3:19
another one that people have been
waiting for a release date for quite
some time
well Final Fantasy 7 remake huh so
here's why I find myself in a crossroads
I've never really played Final Fantasy 7
oh man if taste I will say yeah we'll
say the trailer I thought was good yeah
trailer on its own merit it's just weird
because it is trailer for a remake of a
game that people absolutely die for it's
showing Midgar we know now that the
first part of however many they're not
saying I saw they they don't know I know
because they fairly don't know they said
this will be this will end presumably
okay they did not say it'll end when you
leave Midgard they just did say that
only they did okay no it's Midgar uh
city you might know from Final Fantasy 7
you got our boy cloud here T pi was
shown more right yeah all right I didn't
write mine down imagine the pressure of
making it up Enver such a highly coveted
highly beloved you have the pen Michael
and whether or not you show something or
don't show something is gonna like make
or break everybody this was an intense
moment yeah but will fans ever know your
name editor written random editor who
cut this video URI yeah yeah Carrie
this one's for you there are these clips
Gary Gary way to go Woodbury Gary
alright I'm getting that doc up I'm not
texting I promise yeah tit texted you
ask you what your score was yeah what do
you Nestor this yeah alright everybody
ready yeah flip those boom man you're
sitting you stab you I give it to you I
like I said I get I have to you have to
acknowledge that the Final Fantasy 7 I'm
not saying I'm not knocking the
nostalgia I'm just saying like not
having played it didn't do as much for
me that's this whole beautiful trailer
very good trailer that's the game well
is it Midgar like I'm a surprise we're
still in this environment but it's like
his hair physics and change that to a
night I can only take care many pipes
you know I'm saying yeah more [ __ ] uh
yeah steampunks paradise what are you
more excited for incidentally cyberpunk
or Final Fantasy 7 remake
cyberpunk I'll stop
yeah about you probably cyberpunk yeah
trailer is really beautiful and I did a
higher score to lay the hair physics I
mean look at somebody look like a
dreamboat and they show every character
they give him a nice zoom in sorry I'm
looking at this very cinema talk like a
cinematographer Rex's brilliantly made
let's say I mean compared to like the
Kingdom Hawks the three versions of the
same Kingdom Hearts trailer they were
twice last year with no sound a family
to attend no sound effects oh yeah I
remember that
and then they've stepped up that game
with this alright we're going I'm going
to cross the pond with this one oh my
government yep what uh
Wow okay watchdogs Legion it you can
only mean Australia this game I will
talk more about it once we score it uh
post brexit world we were not allowed
now yes we're supposed to ask him out on
stage
really yeah she just talking about one
in a lot have you been there once it
twice uh that's another right here well
showed a lot of things showing off maybe
any character why keep thinking about
the demo define watchdogs Legion is
probably my game of the show I love
cyberpunk I saw it I love it but if they
pull off hold the top they push you guys
walks with Emma yes I push past the end
get to code I thought you met the demo
during Ubisoft oh no I wouldn't play I
played it today [ __ ]
yeah I want to pick your brain about
that but can you talk about that look
fireman no one told me apart I'm okay
I'll tell you all about it you saw us
gonna rappel down from the ceiling in a
second um alright yeah based on this
trailer flip them
oh sorry you know that yeah oh yeah okay
flip them oh God
yeah I feel like horse I like it okay
what sold fit was allowed I go seven
point fire I know it's quite hard so
yeah well you know alright yeah promise
if again that is probably my game of the
show didn't even get to pie up huh well
I'm a big fan really quick about herbs
like state of decay when you can play as
multiple people in a smaller scale it
looks like they're taking that idea
combining
putting it in an all right city just
making it super it's ambitious as hell
and I kind of go a little bit I know but
I kind it like I don't look like that in
like the hottest e3 games I was feeling
a little bit of white know it's late for
me Ellen because how boy telling me Asaf
right but I kept saying they're slowly
walking up in a very high traffic area
with a pistol Desert Eagle that guy in
the film every time I saw it I lose a
trailer all the gonna pen hell a trailer
gets a seven I kept saying what's the
catch what do you sacrifice court and
make all this happen but how many voice
actors are in this captor playing it I
think I want a number what you sacrifice
it and I loved it too I gave it one
other kind of funny Awards I saw your
face thank you um I think what you're
sacrificing is the bat visual fidelity
slash panache of the main character you
know how to always say like if
everybody's an NPC everybody's face kind
of looks like an NPC yeah yeah which I'm
will I'm totally willing to sacrifice
that going through it and having them
showing systems than I explain how this
is it because it was like I was like but
how are you doing this like do you
really want to know it is again we put
the controller down he explained the way
the game in nanoseconds works it's like
you look at a person and you get their
information you hold our B to scan them
into what that does is build the initial
profile yeah
like while it's scanning them it's like
Oh random generate all this stuff of
where they're from what they're doing
where they're going what their day would
be like I said seeing like what undead
labs there was state of decay even pre
Microsoft funding when they bought them
last year but super impressive and I get
more attached to characters that I'm
telling this yeah I think we all that
you're and you're investing points yeah
you're seeing right and that was the
thing about it like your teeth your
roster can be a max of 20 dental and so
as you go in there you start giving them
perks because you everybody gets three
perks there's like way more than three
though so you're going eat in there's
three different classes then you have
three different parts assigned to it so
you can have a 20-person team that's all
granny infiltrators but they all have
different perks so they're all you know
right for the right job Oh granny until
traitors but it's permadeath
so you fall in love with a character and
you upgrade them and you use them to all
these different campaigns and then they
die yeah it's like a nursing home where
they trained assassins exactly dear God
really good trailer nelson's Greg those
thank you yeah oh yeah that's time
saying that I think excluding what I
would I heard from you what I've seen
in their gameplay the trailer just felt
like more watchdogs and then you're like
oh you can be anyone I guess great I'd
like very narration heavy yeah that the
real I governors are we on that context
ever was there no I'm not sure who that
was yeah okay alright going back to my
kick off again 12-minute like oh yeah
yeah 12 minutes trailer ah
ground hogs day a little bit actually
speaking of apparently the shining
carpet made it into 12 minutes trailer I
didn't see it we got it trailer out this
morning to hmm
most shining roses well you can watch
the trailer but for those who don't know
it's basically setting up its this
couple talking at their table in the
kitchen and this like Quentin Tarantino
upward downward look at the room right
here and you see a couple talking she's
like he's like you got me a present I
know you knew what it was inside my
mother
sounding like dr. Manhattan yeah there's
someone about to knock in the door don't
trust him don't go with him apparently
you're doing like a Groundhog's Day
thing and from what I understand you're
essentially trying to escape a
life-or-death scenario villain or set in
about amount of time loop
yes it's just sounds a better time loops
are so in this year III 2019 the earth
it's just such a different look than any
game I've seen in such a long time it's
top down story driven like a Landingham
you something like that so it's
extremely unique it's extremely
interesting narrative driven you know
they're going to take a lot of time and
care with it because I've seen that this
has been in development for years I'm
really looking forward to seeing this
and this like piqued my interest at
Annapurna so I'm I wanted to say also
side note as a publisher Annapurna has
been killing it weird movies and games
yeah I don't love everybody scored 12
minutes yeah ready flip them huh oh yeah
the dealer yeah yeah the trailer wrong
boy you're not three 9s - hmm it's also
this was PC gaming show this Xbox yes I
did this and then they did that montage
I believe I'm a bunch of games that
sound like well idea Xbox stuff oh it
just did no I think it was just like
beams that we already know Oh like I
think or II know or we got its own thing
yeah we good release window hey Jambi
remind me how much time we have in my
ear but yes um
yeah good drama delight have you really
think that again in this trailer okay
cool I'm pretty telling I'm sorry before
the show they told me I was supposed to
end ten minutes earlier but now my
director is telling me we're ending go
check out I'll figure it out someone
will come out and stop us
I got another I got another one I hope
he has is ready might not who knows I'm
ready for one trailer specifically come
on yeah what about halo infinite wait
why the hold on what do you what do you
want to do Oh [ __ ] oh man come on okay
we're gonna do banjo smash no we don't
have that ready but you're Jong Kook
right I don't throw I don't know
Yeah right - oh man don't smash in
advance a little a little bit of a
bait-and-switch huh debate oh yeah honey
sandwich gonna live a trailer making fun
of another trailer in the same campaign
I love it
where to happen but they're still just
dangling the character in front of ya
okay I don't know if we'll get the
b-roll in time but you all saw you know
go and smash John Luke sorry he doesn't
have it ready well we'll explain it I've
had I've had that job before so I
thought yeah I know I know yeah ramble
exciting real quick this is like dude
it's four minutes to go we have III we
have Nadia to buy with daughter-fucking
city of kink a rule you know it was a
they thought it was him with a shadow
but then it turned out to be something
else something kinky rule company on
they thought it odd kinky rule trailer I
don't remember who like I'm not kinky
rule and then they go back remember that
trailer are we gonna do the same joke
again yeah we are and I just the smashed
trailers when it actually gets in a
gameplay every little bit every like
three second clip is so carefully
constructed and like there's all these
little hidden jokes in there yeah
alright this is why I for one am glad
Reggie's gone he couldn't get this done
but Doug Bowser comes in he's making
deals left and right all right all you
do we're sold now okay alright everybody
ready for a banjo - yeah
flip them so good yeah shoot really good
yeah I only I gave it a no and why
because the persona one destroyed me
sure cuz I am more like I was there the
Game Awards and I think I'd shrieked
whereas this was a very great they very
bright great trailer but I didn't shriek
but Purdy O'Connor characters exactly I
don't care at all about banjo I think it
was a great trailer to review while
we're here what
we talked about bamm-bamm way way home
really awesome
can we rate dogs that we saw at the show
cuz yeah man let's rate that dog who is
a ban-ban there's the dog in the Blair
Witch there's a few dog that's gonna put
bombs out front bullet the dog in blow
the doggy goo every wire that's alone oh
alright bamm-bamm Ilocos why was the
last we're all breaking bamm-bamm now oh
yeah we'll put your numbers down yeah
Oh depend on a favorite kind of dog -
who knows pitbull Thank You 10 Jon
Bernthal has a cute dog doesn't matter
what I'm goes out with ghost wired then
we'll see which wins yeah yeah so ghost
what sorry
Tokyo ghost where'd goes right ochio we
had this argument upstairs and I think I
was also wrong up there oh Swire Tokyo
I'm so mad I'm not gonna bother remember
the right answer right Tokyo uh
very surprising because I think most
people thought Shinji Mikami was here
for evil 1 in 3 which would have been
awesome but here we have some sort of
rapture happening in Tokyo and people
are just getting lifted into some other
universe and their clothes are left
behind super creepy there's a dude with
a bow and arrow and like a hazmat hoodie
single-handedly the best cut slash
transition of any trailer I think I've
ever seen whittles oops yes Derby web
you know listening also side note uh I
forget her name her people the woman who
everybody is falling in love with this
yep in here ma'am um none of us are
gonna help you know yeah I'm at work
Stuart thanks for calling us out key
right thanks appreciate that I just
trying to embarrass myself that's right
we're all terrible people everybody
ready yeah yeah yeah yeah no all knives
not 10 it'll cut all my love the no 10 I
loved it clarification it's definitely
noodles food like just like purely for
the nudes really I was gonna say said
nudes yes cinematic and Atmospheric this
trailers fantastic yeah
and alright yeah the only downside I was
like if she explained beforehand but not
getting a better taste of what gameplay
was like what was the game we're talking
about her death yeah thing yeah yeah
same conference too
boo-ki judges right everybody well one
jean-luc you know when one told us but
otherwise this train nobody taking okay
I think a full scarred I got the answer
I'll reveal in a second when we close
out but I want to hear everybody's game
of show Verdi was a trailer
whether you played it or not what are
you most excited for coming out of e3
you're not ready no definitely post
cyberpunk okay yeah 170 Punk double sev
yeah frags defunct double sev brown
faces heaven remake
okay alright here's four five rod came
up to show that before the broke that
State Road to offer mention every day oh
yeah that the a skate mode looks because
I'm always here's my watchdogs lead you
I'm so excited I think it's me great guy
oh my game is trail was watchdogs Legion
according to these five super experts
the best trailer of e3
mm I team was seapunk double sev yeah
watch for that and I wonder why is he
here
I was hoping Keanu would be here dude
I've tried to mine I just saw he was
like I'm Mike Tyson it uh yeah yeah a
friend of mine was in the hotel room
next to Kiana race and like bumped into
him getting Isaac my party kid the same
hotel room is Hamid he honors my friend
oh no I did that stop your heart him
getting ice cuz he's perfect he's like
the cold beverage yeah okay alright love
him I've never seen you get ice try
glass the ice machine on the fridge is
broken
okay first off is the only person who
steals the ice trays in them and then
the house don't even start
it's become a roommate wobble yeah this
is how we air uh three people in the
building Mike are in our apartment guess
how many people take out their cycling
one it's you you it's heavy it's a lot
of hair it builds up stop wasting side
if they would do it more frequently
right right Jen and Lucy wouldn't build
it I know what I doubt all right
unfortunate we're out of time and III is
kind of essentially over especially for
all intents purse here on the stage show
Mary thank you so much for joining us as
always uh to meet you when we record the
next episode of Knievel that's right
Brandon Jones it was nice to meet you in
person for me finally
trailers good trailers trailers are
great a good year of trailers would you
say overall good uh yeah there was it I
liked a lot of them there really wasn't
that one like
really crazy stand out like that was a
great moment but you know solid right it
was it's always yeah I am pleased yeah
and you go Seymour Brandon on easy
allies if you don't already keep up with
them Greg Miller for kind of funny thank
you so much for joining us thanks for
everything despite being on your show a
few times it's the first time you and I
have been on today's exactly think when
I got to go somewhere I like Mike can do
it yeah yeah Lucy hey you'll probably
see more of me yeah we work together yep
anyway everybody thank you whether in
the live audience or at home thank you
so much for joining throughout the whole
week we had a lot of great interviews
you can go see those on youtube.com
slash GameSpot or on gamespot.com
probably have some on Facebook I don't
even have a Facebook anymore
but we were so glad you could join us
all throughout this week Lucy it's done
we did it thanks everyone again and
thank you for watching go catch up on
all the news I'm gonna go sleep
[Music]